هناك من يوقظك
في الصباح يخبرك أن لديك
رسالة مفادها أن غدائك جاهز
لإغلاق باب الثلاجة عبر رسائل البريد الإلكتروني والمكالمات الهاتفية
التي تستدعي اضطراب رسائل Facebook
وأدناه ، وقد أنشأ باحث معين
هذا المنبه للوقوف
من بين الحشود إنذار لإيقاف
تصادم السيارة وجهاً لوجه ، اسمها كارول
بالدوين وأنا مديرة
العوامل البشرية ، برنامج الإدراك التطبيقي
في جامعة جورج ميسون ،
فكيف يمكنك البدء في إنشاء واحد
من أكثر البرامج المزعجة في العالم  الأصوات التي
بدأناها من خلال الخروج والحصول على
تسجيلات للأصوات الفعلية الموجودة في
السيارات حاليًا وأخذنا هذه
الأصوات مرة أخرى إلى المختبر بمجرد
جمع الأصوات ، فقد حان الوقت للاختبار
على الأشخاص الذين أنشأوا نظامًا
يمكن للمستمع فيه تشغيل صوت  ثم
ضعه في فئة تم تمثيل الصوت فيها
إما بإلحاح منخفض مثل
إشعار facebook وإلحاح متوسط المدى مث
تنبيه محرك الفحص وأ
يراً ارتفاع l  مستوى الإلحاح مثل
امرأة تصادم قادمة ومن ثم
قمنا بإعداد سلسلة من
دراسات محاكاة القيادة وهم يقودون
سياراتهم ويقومون بمهمة أخرى
فقط لمنحهم عنصر تشتيت
ومن ثم فجأة سيارة غير متوقعة
أنهم '  قد تنكسر إعادة المتابعة
فجأة ونظرنا في استجابة تجنب الاصطدام الخاصة بهم
على توقيت ذلك ، حيث
قاموا بإنشاء
إنذار تحذير الاصطدام الأمامي المثالي وهذا أمر
مهم حقًا لأننا وجدنا
أن الأصوات المستخدمة
حاليًا تعتبر ملحة للغاية ، فأنت تعلم
أن تصميمًا سيئًا  يمكن أن يكون الصوت أكثر
خطورة من عدم وجود تحذير على
الإطلاق ، لذا نشكرك على استخدام
الصوت الأكثر إزعاجًا لك